so thank you
today i will talk about
quality assurance in machine learning
so
which means basically i will concentrate
on machine learning specific
vulnerabilities and how we can audit
machine learning models
or in other words how we can test them
and for what
so let's start with vulnerable
vulnerabilities of the machine learning
so
we all love machine learning it is great
it achieves tremendous success in many
fronts
but
especially the recent literature showed
us that
our bloat machine learning models are
susceptible to
different kind of
attacks and
they are somehow vulnerable to
some flows which i will cover uh later
on so basically what i mean is that
we have
kind of adversarial examples that are
very problematic for machine learning
models and which is mostly
um related to the security of the
machine learning models
and
uh i'll also touch a little bit on the
privacy issues with machine learning
models because they are especially the
big models likely to leak private
information the information that is
in the that is present in the training
set
we all know that
yeah very especially when we talk about
deep learning we all know that they are
black box
and for
for some use cases we really want to
understand and explain why an ml model
comes up with a specific prediction or
decision
but in this talk i will mostly
ignore this one
and it doesn't fit exactly to the
testing concept
but you can keep that in mind and
the last thing is the
fairness issues of of machine learning
models
when it comes to
decision making
so
for six or seven years we know that
people can really easily tweak
examples
or observations
so that
they can trick or fool the machine
learning models
so if you look at the
stop sign
at the left hand side the most left-hand
side image okay it is for humans it is a
clearly stop sign and
for many of the computer vision models
it is with very high confidence at stop
sign but
if we put
as
spatially crafted little stickers
on that side on that shield
as humans we still recognize that it's a
stop sign but
our computer vision models really
full about its class and
it predicts that it is
something other like a turtle or a dog a
cat or whatever
and
the bad thing is that we can craft
inputs or stickers so that we can
manipulate the machine learning model
however we like we can make that model
to predict that it is a 200
speed sign
so that
when
an autonomous autonomous driving car
sees that sign
it should increase its speed to 200 or
something like that
which is actually
possible as you see at the right hand
side so a couple of years ago people
really tricked or fooled the computer
vis object detection
or design traffic sign detection system
of tesla
so that they just
as you see here they a little bit played
with the tree there and
now the tesla
auto pilot recognizes its increased
speed to 85. so it has really
serious security
considerations
and
it is not just computer vision i mean
it's not just computer vision
you can really pull any kind of model
models that are trained on text data
models that are trained on tabular data
models that are trained on audio data it
doesn't matter you can craft these
inputs very easily that is the problem
other than that okay so you may
conceptualize the adversarial examples
like the security
aspect of
machine learning robustness but we also
have other problems like privacy issues
so sometimes we train our models from on
the data that contains
private and sensitive information like
the patient's information
their specific diseases
or we train models on emails on people's
cvs you know
any kind of that
but we learned that
especially the large language models
like gp23 to
birth-based models
really memorize
that training
that sensitive information from the
training data
and to be able to memorize a sensitive
information some very large model
requires it to see
see that example only a couple of times
in the training set
and
when you craft a spatial
prefix
to a let's say a language generation
model it spits out
that private information like the emails
of a person or the past
illnesses
or credit card number
whatever so i put this image here
from
a paper from last year
because it doesn't contain
very serious sensitive information
because gp22 is trained on you know
public data
but
if you fine-tune this kind of models
with your private with the data that
that contains private information then
you should make sure that
they they don't leak that sensitive
information during inference time
and it is not just an academic toy or
game
you can craft all of these attacks into
the real world
for example at the right hand side
you can see that our web loud yolo
algorithm recognizes the guy at the left
hand side as a person
but
the other guy who puts a sticker okay a
special sticker in front of him
you know for for that guy
the old algorithm version two three
really
doesn't recognize him as a person so i
can print that stickers for you
in a t-shirt you can wear that t-shirt
and you can just bypass the security
offen of an institution if they use
such a system
and any kind of things you know it's it
can be really transferable to to the
physical world
another thing is the fairness
so
we are now quite
knowledgeable about that the machine
learning models really easily learn
the biases in in their training set
and
probably you heard some of those you
know news about how
bias and machine learning algorithm can
be there are a couple of examples here
you know uh recently in in
holland's
and an algorithm uh you know wrongly
accused thousands of people
fraud on child care data
just
yeah
just based on their ethnical
things or or things like that yeah and
we all know that gp3 is has
some serious bias problems as well so
this is very concerning if you are
developing
nlp solutions based on large models
which
you should do right this is the start
state of that at the moment so you
somehow you should get a large language
model find fine tune on your use case on
your data and use it you cannot train
any gp3 or bert or whatever it's too
costly
but be remind that you are transferring
all these vulnerabilities into your
systems
yet another problem with the machine
learning models is their generalization
capability
okay we train our models on the train
sets and
ultimately we test them on the test set
right
why because we believe that test set is
a good proxy for the real world i mean
when we deployed production
and that model sees the real data that's
coming from the real world we expect or
we hope that the distributions of the
two the real-world distribution
anti-test distribution is the same so
that is why we tested on the test data
but
it is usually not the case
i mean
this is a very edgy example here
when you call it
breaks
uh
yeah no one would expect any model to to
predict that such a
such a very
hard shock you know would change
everything but
you can just think about our
generalization issues you are predicting
your sales
and you are introducing a new product
which can be
complementary to your existing products
which means a distribution shift for
your
forecast for example
so
how to make sure
thanks god
some community
some communities maintain
some good resources for you to convince
yourself that
machine learning models can be
problematic
so for example ai incident database you
can
go
hit that web page and see what kind of
things
occur in real life people report some ai
incidences
from the last month
some police officer
needed to stop
an autonomous
autonomous car
because the car didn't
light their
lights on didn't put their lights on
so
you can find some
good examples of that
sorry
okay so
machine learning in the end needs
red teams and blue teams so i talked
about attacking
models and their vulnerabilities i
didn't
mention about how the defenses how they
can make them better or something like
that let's forget that at the moment
and
just appreciate that the fact that we
need
red teams to attack machine learning
models for security front or on security
front or fairness front or data
distribution you know anything all those
kind of vulnerabilities
and
we need blue teams to
fix those vulnerabilities
for us hopefully
but at the end of the day
we don't have enough resources you know
we
expect everything from our good old data
scientists or machine learning engineers
so they should develop state-of-the-art
models to solve a business problem at
the same time they need to make sure
that
everything is fine when you deploy them
in production
good
thing is that
governments across the world started to
appreciate this fact the vulnerabilities
of the machine learning and they started
to think about putting regulations in
place
so the most recent one is the european
commission's proposal
on regulating ai systems
in this talk when i mean ai i mostly
mean machine learning okay you can
assume that as well
the the whole idea of the european
commission's regulation is that we can
classify machine learning models into
high-risk systems and the others
and then
what we mean by high risk is that if
your products or services
contains a machine learning part or
itself can be a machine learning service
and if it relates to the security health
of the real persons or the human rights
then it is by definition high-risk ai
system
so
of course at the moment it's its
proposal and in a couple of years in two
years we expect it to be in place all
across europe
across the european union
so if your your
ml model serves or ml model is
one of those high risks high risk
systems then you need to properly test
your models
before you put them in production you
are not allowed to put them in
production without providing
your test reports and in some cases even
you need to test your systems to to the
external parties independent parties
it's like how you test your
cars to some external or tooth
in germany
it will be something like that
so um
yeah
for this fact
or the the
the
upcoming regulations
really makes us to think about how to
properly test machine learning models
and how can we make sure that everything
is fine when we deploy them in
production
so
there is a definition of the higher high
risk ai system in the proposal but it
can it's likely to change in the course
of the time but it will be you know
around the one that i just explained
so
what matters is whether it's relates to
safety of the people or or the human
human rights
so
in addition to that there are some
special things categories
which by definition goes into the high
risk category
and if you are for example working in a
public institution for example gas
supply water supply electric supply
transportation
then you will most likely be in in that
category high risk category and you need
to test your machine learning models
but
there can be others like
cd companies
because if you automate this first
selection of the cvs you know using some
ml or something like that you should
make sure that your algorithms are not
biased
yeah so uh there are some other examples
as well
so the regulation boundary is
a
actually like this
so you need to validate your machine
learning models on privacy things
security things
fairness
and once you deploy them you need to
monitor your ml models
with human in the loop approach okay
so which means that you need to lock
every prediction of your model
and you need to
detect if something serious happening in
the production
and if something serious happening then
you can you should be able to interfere
with the system okay and if needed you
should fall back to the humans
for high-risk ai systems
this will be mandatory
so you kind of
need a good logger an anomaly detection
or an mlml firewall on your monitoring
stack
and
another part of that is the
explainability
uh which is kind of you all know
familiar from the financial
finance domain you know
which is already regulated
some degree and so for some use cases
you need to explain your models
so what does this mean so this is the
classical machine learning pipeline we
gather the data
make some data mongolian data cleaning
data transformation then
we should come up with some features and
train some models on our train set
and
using the test set we should
find out which model performs best you
know it's we also look at the
generalization by looking at the
difference between train set and test
set or whatever so this is roughly the
classical machine learning pipeline but
this is where we are going
now
you need to
when you train your
data
you now not just only look at the
performance metrics but you should all
you should also look at some other
metrics regarding fairness data drift
security
and
and and the others
and you should also produce some
technical documents to provide to the
regulator authorities
and
a user instruction and user manual
that explain what users can expect from
your machine learning models
and when you once you deploy those
models you need to put in place a
full-fledged incident response
with with human human in the loop
approach
so let's
concentrate on the testing part of that
yeah we should somehow change our
classical pipeline
uh
to something like this which integrates
ml testing as a first class citizen okay
now what we need to do is as i said
before not just performance metrics we
also need some additional metrics to
test our models
it is some metrics from fairness domain
like
fairness metric or some metrics that
measure
hopefully the data drift or some other
metrics that hopefully capture the
security level of your machine learning
models but in the end
we should look at that
and this is a best practice not just
because of regulations or whatever okay
because we know that when you increase
the security
weaknesses or when you've remade the
security problems of your models you
also tend to increase the generalization
capability of that as well
okay so
in any case this this
is something that we can appreciate as a
as a machine learning community
and human end is in the loop
when monitoring that system is very
critical
if you are familiar with cyber security
this is something like shock
teams they just monitor the environments
and
and
get into play when needed
okay let's talk
more concretely on how to test machine
learning models
i will not go very much into details of
the everything so i will just give you
an overview so we have very limited time
but
yeah this is the four pillars of
transparty or robust ai so you should
concentrate on security privacy
which we know from my explanations
before and reliability regarding the
distribution shifts and the
explainability
aspect so before
going more detail some general remarks
as you all know as a machine learning
engineers or data scientist we all know
that data transitions from stage to
stage we get the raw data
we somehow prepare it through to the
analysis
and we extract feature and some features
from that data whatever
so this is a data supply chain and
as a general rule
if you
if you
play on your data early enough then you
are more likely to
to prevent the escalation of the
problems so the earlier in the in this
data supply chain
these the tests are are the better and
easier to to apply
the second is that
we should consider several threat models
okay
whether black box access is the only way
to access your ml systems or some gray
or white box access is possible this
really changed the security aspects of
your models so
when you are working in a company and
developing an ml model you should now
specify your threat models and take
actions
in that respect
and
now put security fairness and data drift
at least these three of the kind of
tests into your ml pipeline
and put in place
uh
monitoring infrastructure incident
response infrastructure
for for your for your production
environment
so
let's talk about security issues as i
told you before we know that machine
learning models are susceptible to
adversarial examples and they are easy
to
create actually for many of the models
so we call this kind of attacks as
evasion attacks
and
the the
the the goal of the aviation attacks is
to manipulate the predictions of your
models
and the bad thing is that we can go to
your model however we like
we make your model to predict cat as a
dog specifically
another type of attacks that is related
to security is the poisoning attacks if
you are constantly getting data from
external environments
and
regularly train your models using that
data
then you are opening a poisoning attack
surface for your models
people can put specially crafted inputs
that you don't notice when collecting
the data
and everything when everything goes fine
in production people can
can trigger a specific example which
manipulates that model according to
their wishes so it's like a time bomb or
something like that
and another thing about the security of
your model is distilling attacks
yeah people can train student models
using your model as a teacher student
as a teacher model and at the end of the
end of the day they can steal your model
uh which means
uh and intellectual property of your
company might be at risk
how these attacks
work
at the left side you see how the evasion
attacks work
it does query your model okay if they
access to the to your
predictions of your model that's enough
that's enough they don't need to know
the inner details of your model just
generates even sometimes just put
random examples random queries to your
model and see what kind of return what
kind of output it returns especially if
your models
produce
probabilities
return
outcome
as probabilities then people can train
their own student model
and when they apply adversarial attack
techniques to that student model
that examples
most of the time also
work on your model
this is
what we call transferability of the
attacks
and it is what makes everything very
dangerous people really don't need to
get inner details of your models in text
models i mean if you are developing an
nlp
model for some task using birth or
something like that people can
attack your models easily because the
attack attacking points or they're
taking examples that work on
pure birth would
most likely work on your case for on
your fine-tuned model as well
so the python
python offers great tools open source
tools to test
your models so the the my favorite tool
for testing a model uh in this direction
is the art the adversarial robustness
toolbox it offers many state-of-the-art
algorithms for you it offers many
attack types and defenses as well i mean
if you would like to play with in this
area you can just
start doing that using art
it was initiated by ibm now it's managed
under linux foundation
and another thing is the clever hands
it is not not managed by the vector
institute in canada it also it's also a
good toolkit to to for adversarial
attacks and security testing of your
models
when it comes to privacy
okay you
you can test your models
uh yeah i mean as i said before the
larger your model gets
the
more likely it's it memorizes the the
information in your training data so be
careful with large models and also keep
in mind that transfer learning
trans transfers
the vulnerabilities to define to find
models as well so
so be careful
on what kind of
pre-trained model are you using when you
apply a transfer learning scheme
and
unfortunately we don't have good
solutions or defenses for that the only
viable solution seems to be differential
privacy
but it is really impractical if your
data set
or
model gets too large it's it's compute
costs are very high and you should also
keep in mind that uh differential
privacy cause some accuracy for your
models as well
so yes this is just
an example of membership inference
attacks membership inference attacks it
means that
similar to evasion attacks people query
your models and try to
guess whether a specific example is in
your train set or not so they can
um
with a great success they can determine
that okay this example is part of your
training data which means your training
information
uh can be stolen by the external parties
it doesn't only related to text
models
people can also
apply model inversion attacks
to steal
for example uh images from your
from your mothers please
yes right now
i think i have
time to 35
yes it was five minutes for
questions but uh yeah so i have 15
minutes right
okay i mean according to the agenda i
have but uh yeah
okay let me quit the wrap up
so okay you have some tools to test your
privacy issues as well so i will not go
over that okay
uh
i will share the presentation
we also are interested
and uh yeah you can apply some testing
using the python ecosystem so it it has
a great ecosystem when it comes to
machine learning validation and testing
okay you can
especially for failures you can make use
of ai fairness which is also part of the
linux foundation
but if you get bored you can just
get out of the club it's fine
but anyway i speed it up so
yeah about data drift i mean there are
some
couple of data drift concepts
it's about
changing the distributions okay changing
the distributions you can test them
using some statistical methods
yeah when you get the presentation you
will get the packages and the links you
can just follow
so that you can use by yourself okay so
what to do
so the first thing to do
okay change your way of doing ml keep
track of the versions of ml models if
you don't
do that at the moment you can do that
using animal obstacle
but
if you don't you are not using a demo
obstacle make sure that you need to keep
track of the versions because you need
to be able to associate the production
predictions with the specific model
versions so it is something mandatory
as i said test your models for security
fairness
privacy and data drifts along with the
performance metrics and
for
defenses against adversarial attacks
usually adverse adversarial training is
the only way to increase the robustness
of your models so put some adversarial
examples in your training sets it is
like adding using a data augmentation
technique okay
and
be prepared to write good documentation
so it is
something that you need to do as well
so
i will
uh introduce quickly the validator that
we are developing
at kit a classroom institute for
technology
which we will make open source during
this year we are still working on that
so this is the tool and autonomous tool
end-to-end tool
that automates everything every testing
for you you just give your machine
learning model saved models and data
sets and
write your test as a config so you don't
have to learn
the nitty-gritties of every testing by
yourself
so
when we open source it you can just you
know you start using it adopting it at
your company and um so it offers testing
and monitoring in a single place
so as i said before
it offers it covers both of them because
there are some feedback loops between
testing phase and the monitoring phase
because
to detect for example problematic
instances or examples in in the
production we may need some information
from the test site they said that is why
this system
follows a holistic approach on this okay
and it can integrate with your current
envelopes tools if you are already
using them
yeah it keeps versioning it runs tests
on your behalf it is like a cicd tool
so if you are familiar with software
development lifecycle like jenkins
travis or whatever you just push your
models to
a repo and or all of your unit tests run
right you just need to write those unit
tests only once so this is similar here
you just need to define the tests as a
config and it will just run it every
time you push your model a repository so
you will get the reports you will
integrate it with your production
pipeline so if some thresholds are not
met you can prevent it your model going
into into the production
so
we don't expect ml engineers to know
everything
and
so it is kind of an
new
field in machine learning and it
requires its own expertise
okay
so
but it should be you know you should
somehow integrate ml testing in your
workflow so that you don't spend too
much time on that but can concentrate on
what you need to do which is developing
or solving a business problem
and this field is changing rapidly i
mean it is almost impossible to catch up
with state of the art
if you want to apply these things by
yourself every time you need to spend
really good amount of time to catch up
with the literature so
that is why
we are developing this one
in at kit with the support of the body
with my government by the way
okay so
uh
this is all so we are looking for better
users if you are interested you can just
write me
and i will somehow share these slides
with you so that you can
get to know those great packages
in the python ecosystem so you can start
using that to ensure the quality
assurance in your machine learning
endeavors so thank you
thank you sorry about the time confusion
uh does anyone has any questions i can't
see anything on slido so if you have any
questions please raise your hand
okay
thank you very much for the interesting
talk i wonder if there are similar
regulations for software systems or is
it now really a new thing that just
applies and is expected from ai systems
so um because software systems have
similar vulnerabilities not all of them
obviously but probably yes but the from
your regulation point of view this is
ai is something different because it
makes decision making
okay
like
it's reads the uh mr images and diagnose
and an illness or something like that or
it's is used in autonomous driving which
is directly related to the safety of the
people
so that is why
high-risk ai systems
are something
that should be
created something different it's like we
humans
because they are to do what we are
supposed to do
that's why these regulations
put focus on high-risk ai systems so
it's it's kind of different from that
in terms of their consequences
please thank you any more questions okay
i'll come to him and then you're next
sorry i think i'm first
um yeah so just a short answer for my
previous question
depending on your sector yes there are
definitely regulations in software
development as well coming from
healthcare i know that pretty much
but i have another question you
mentioned
in the middle of your talk that a
whitebox model would be
able to prevent or circumvent some of
the
issues that occur with a black box model
around the security of the model could
you maybe give an example of no no i
didn't say that okay sorry and i didn't
understand that right model if you can
apply white box attacks it is more
problematic because you have much more
data than black boxer text that's
for sure
yeah but at the end of the day
the gradients if you know what i mean
the gradients are very dangerous things
and if you can access the gradients of a
model
you can really really reveal almost
anything even the training data from
that gradient information
yeah please
can i know
okay
so thanks um you mentioned earlier this
poisoning attacks
um
do you have an explicit example like how
that works and what we can and
um
explain again please like okay i will
just give a toy example
things like that you are automatic
automated your credit card application
or credits applications using an ml
model and
every time i put my
things my information
i got rejected because of my salary or
whatever
but i just tweaked your my example so
every time i've requested a credit you
know i
increase my
i don't know my square feet of my home
or something like that
and
that information purchasing your
database and if you are using that
information okay
uh
if and if i crafted those perturbations
on the on the examples carefully
i can invoke a positive credit
think by just
making my
salary from 30 000 to 29 000 okay
and i get credits
accepted
it is
because of the
continuous learning
flow of your model so if you are doing
online learning or active learning
that you train periodically with the new
con
the data that's coming from production
system you should be careful
thank you any more questions
no
okay one more question here
i was just curious if the kind of extra
layers of work involved with this
testing will have an effect on the
viability of machine learning in
different cases due to the cost
associated
i i really couldn't understand can you
please more
so
what i was curious about is because of
the extra work involved with the testing
yeah if that will affect the viability
of models in different cases because it
will be more expensive to develop the
machine learning
in some way
yes i mean
it is it is costly in terms of time
you should invest in testing
but it is something that you need to do
if you are developing a high-risk ai
system okay this is the price that you
should pay but people are developing
tools to make your life easier
uh
that is why people you know like like us
in in the universe are developing tools
for the community so that you can use
use it and open source it because we
know we follow the literature we know
the best practices we know the state of
the attacks and you know the state of
the defenses but no one expects you
as an ml engineer in the industry to to
know
or to be up to date with the literature
so that is why you need to somehow use a
quality management system
in your in your organization otherwise
it will be very costly and
it will be at this moment impossible to
find good ml validators or
hackers
thank you very much
thank you i think time is up you upload
the slides and
thank you thank you very much